you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
the eu proposes full embargo on russian
oil but not all member states are on
board
nearly 200 million people face food
insecurity across the world conflict and
economic shocks intensify by climate
crisis
and can meditation help officials in
their mission to achieve substantial
climate action we'll be discussing that
with our panel
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and reports on the race for
solutions
now the european union has proposed an
embargo on russian imports of russian
oil in the latest response to the
invasion of ukraine now the sanctions
are yet to be approved with several
member states still reliant on russian
fossil fuels commission president ursula
von der lyon admitted the task will not
be easy some member states are strongly
dependent on russian oil
but we simply have to do it
so today we will propose
to ban all russian oil from europe we
will make sure that we phase out russian
oil in an orderly fashion
so in a way that allows us and our
partners to secure alternative supply
routes and at the same time be very
careful
that we minimize the impact on the
global market
russian oil accounted for more than a
quarter of the blocks imports in 2020
and while the uk and u.s have been able
to ban russian oil on a much shorter
time frame the eu has announced a plan
to phase out russian crude oil imports
over the next six months
now refined oil will end in 2022
but members such as hungary and slovakia
are heavily reliant on supplies from
russia with hungary receiving 58
of their oil from russia's last year and
slovakia receiving
96
coming from russia there well despite a
suggestion that those countries would
have an extended deadline to phase out
imports hungary has rejected the
proposal in its current form our europe
correspondent siobhan robbins is in
berlin
well after much speculation
announcements today about proposals to
ban
oil imports by the eu from russia now if
this was to go ahead the plan would be
that crude oil imports would be banned
in the next six months and by the end of
the year imports of processed oil a big
move for eu states who all 27 need to
support this in order for it to go
through now before this was announced
there were big concerns in about three
countries in particular germany slovakia
and hungary and in recent days actually
germany has said that it would support a
ban on oil imports from russia that's
because essentially since the war in
ukraine has started the country has been
working hard to try and find alternative
supplies so it now feels like it has got
a backup plan now hungary and slovakia
are a different matter they they rely
very strongly on russian oil but it's
interesting because i've been speaking
to activists both here in germany and
also those with links to hungary and
they've been saying this just doesn't go
far enough the idea that crude oil could
continue to be supplied for the next six
to eight months gives vladimir putin the
option to find other customers and over
in hungary they're saying well actually
we shouldn't be clinging on to supplies
of dirty
oil from russia instead we should be
looking for renewable supplies and
secure energy supplies to stop us being
hostages in the future
let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and a spike in oil and
gas prices triggered by the war in
ukraine could see energy giants
increasing their profits by 111 this
year from north sea operations alone now
analysts from greenpeace and oil change
international found the money made from
north sea fossil fuel operations is
projected to increase by
11.6 billion pounds and campaigners are
calling on a windfall tax to invest the
money elsewhere
this isn't money that we're taking out
of the pockets of the oil industry
because it's money they would never have
seen in the first place investing some
of that in increased
efficiency in building so insulation
particularly in in the uk's really
terrible heating stock but also using
some of that money to train up heating
engineers to make sure that zero carbon
heating uh things like heat pumps can be
both efficiently effectively and less
expensively installed uh and and and
making sure that our ambition around
renewable energy and energy efficiency
matches the urgency of the situation
that we face
a new study has revealed the most
intense heat waves ever across the world
and that several went largely unreported
over the past decade so last summer
litten in british columbia experienced a
record-breaking 49.6 degrees celsius but
research led by the university of
bristol showed the most extreme heat
wave that's when temperatures were
highest in comparison to the average in
that location was in southeast asia in
april 1998 when temperatures hit
32.8 degrees celsius
now replacing 20 of global beef
consumption with microbreedial protein
by 2050 could halve annual deforestation
and the associated co2 emissions it's a
single cell protein used for food which
is typically made up of fungi and
alternative meats need less farming land
and the study published in the journal
nature backs up previous research on the
impact of livestock farming on
climate change
and billy eilish has announced she'll
host a six-day climate change festival
in london next month as part of her
world tour now the singer is organizing
a series of activities including
discussions on green issues live
performances and a documentary viewing
topics will range from green practices
in the music industry to the benefits of
a plant-based diet and sustainable
fashion
now the number of people facing serious
hunger across the world rose sharply
last year humanitarian agencies said in
a report published today now the number
of people facing food insecurity across
the world rose by 40 million to
193 million in
2021. now the three primary drivers and
were conflict and insecurity economic
shocks mainly the covid pandemic and
extreme weather longer and more extreme
drought severe cyclones and flooding
from extreme rainfall now 53 countries
were included
in this report and those factors played
a combined role i suppose in the worst
affected countries which included
ethiopia
yemen and afghanistan
but extreme weather events intensified
by climate change were the primary
driver of acute food insecurity for 23.5
million people in eight countries across
africa well joining me now to
discuss this is rebecca richards chief
of emergencies uh with the world food
programme thank you so much for joining
us rebecca this is a stark report isn't
it what are your thoughts overall
overall i'm actually
really surprised that the numbers are as
high as they are we've always known it
was coming and it's incredible when you
look especially at climate change
it takes a long time it's no big
surprise and there's enough technology
for us to be able to look and predict at
what is around the corner but when you
look at the numbers and actually if you
look also at the impact of the ukraine
crisis it's getting worse and worse and
worse and the bottom line is there's
enough food in the world to feed
everyone so it doesn't make sense that
we're in the situation where you have so
many on the brink of
um you mentioned some of the countries
towards um southern part of africa so
maybe i'll just give you one highlight
if you look at somalia
the continued below average rainfall is
going to see potentially 81 000 people
being pushed right into the brick
towards famine
this year
unless we're able to do something about
it so yes overall i am worried i think
the evidence is there for us to plan
differently and to work differently and
it really has come to a point now where
we need a multi-stakeholder approach and
we need to start taking this really
seriously
rebecca can you just explain to us why
climate change is making the food crisis
worse
well it starts to erode people's
capacity to cope
so if you look for example at the
drought
many of the farmers especially
smallholder farmers who provide
production for their own countries are
losing their ability to actually farm
and and deliver the crops at scale not
just for their own families but for the
broader broader country and that
gradually shrinking space has a huge
knock-on effect on the economy of the
country that's just one example you also
have
um
sudden shocks and when it comes to
flooding or earthquakes these are
getting worse and worse and pushing much
more severely people in that into need
when it comes to humanitarian emergency
assistance
so
this when you intertwine it
with the conflict like you mentioned
earlier or if you if you include it also
into the equation of the impact covert
then it just exacerbates makes the whole
situation so much more worse
and rebecca briefly this is the hardest
question of all
what are the solutions
lee you know that it's complicated and
each region in each country is going to
need a different type of solution but if
i could dumb it down i think we're
looking at three areas of work that
really need to happen if we're going to
see change number one we're going to
help to save lives but at the same time
we've got to try to change lives we've
got to build the resilience of
populations and that means tackling the
root causes of hunger at the same time
that you're trying to get food to people
and that's a two-pronged approach it's
got to happen at the same time it's also
got to happen in the same areas the
second is that you've got to plan
differently for us to make long-term
change we've got to be looking at the
policies and countries we've got to be
looking at a wide variety of issues that
affect the global supply chain that's
export tariffs um that's being able to
move and transport it's been able to
stop pilots being able to store food and
make sure that it's in there's no loss
of food all these need to be considered
and then finally you need to really
bring the community together and i'm
talking about breaking down those silos
and bringing together the private sector
with the un with ngos together with
governments to really start to change
the data and bring joint plans that have
a much more longer-term approach to
tackling the problem
okay rebecca thank you very much for
your insights
well do stay with us coming up
i'll be joined by zeppy golzari monroe
deputy director at the energy and
climate intelligence unit and assad
raymond director of war on want will be
discussing what the global food crisis
will be and what can be done and
meditation can it help bureaucrats
tackle climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news um well let's
discuss some of today's climate issues
now with sepi gulzari monroe deputy
director at the energy and climate
intelligence unit and
assad raymond director of war on want
now the big story that we're talking
today is news that the number of people
facing food insecurity across the world
has shot up to nearly 200 million now
the reasons of course complex but it's
clear that increased drought storms and
flooding are playing an important role
and in this report from 2021 it doesn't
even take into account the effects of
the war in ukraine one of the world's
biggest wheat exporters so let me start
uh with you as a 200 million people
across the globe that's such a big
number are you surprised by that
uh actually i'm not they've been
countless warnings that we're now
entering a period of what he's been
called a hunger pandemic whether it's
climate famines in madagascar or even
here in the uk one of the richest
economies in the world where you know
one in 10 families are using food banks
because they can't afford the increase
in food prices
we are moving from the relative stable
period in our planet's history when
human beings were able to grow crops
develop agriculture and have stable
civilizations that's clearly coming to
an end and as rightly the report points
out there are many different elements to
this crisis but you know what's
important is for us to think about these
things connected joining the dots
between whether it's climate health
poverty and hunger
um
because what's stark about this figure
is it talks about the 200 million figure
for famine right that's acute hunger but
actually globally there's about two
billion people who face food insecurity
and close to about a billion people will
go hungry today so they won't have
enough food to feed themselves or their
families and that of course number is
increasing yeah as the report says we
could feed the world three times over so
why aren't we doing that well
fundamentally there's a we have a broken
food system um
we have nearly eighty percent of the
world which is being fed by small farms
but they're only on a tiny percentage of
land about 25 globally and in the cross
continent of africa less than 15 percent
now you listeners might ask so what's
happening with the rest of the land well
the rest of the land is controlled by
what is called industrial farming mega
corporations who produce commodities for
the world markets soy sugar cane palm
oil and they're like the fossil fuel
industry are intended to racking up the
hugest profit they can and they're
actually responsible also for about a
third of global emissions and what we've
seen is that our food systems are being
controlled by these mega corporations
just four corporations control seventy
five percent of what will are global
trade interest grain
six control about seventy five percent
of all pesticides and ten companies
control much of our food brands so they
decide what kind of food we eat how much
we pay and how much damage is done but
there are solutions to this and and and
farmers organizations and presidents and
we as warren won't work with many of
them could be provo proposing these
solutions they say look we can cool this
planet and feed people we can call for a
global green new deal we can call for
food me made a fundamental right for
everyone but we can most importantly
tackle this food system by giving land
rights to those who actually produce the
food that feeds the world so it's not a
story just of doom and gloom but it is a
really important part of recognizing
that this climate crisis isn't simply
about fossil fuels it's also about the
future you're not shocked by it we'll
get on to more on to the solutions in a
moment but zapier i guess what this
shows is that climate change is now a
security risk just as war
absolutely um i think the critical point
i'd highlight to start off with is
really that this is a vicious cycle
climate change drives food insecurity
but our means of production the way that
we use our land and the way that we
produce
food is also driving the the climate
crisis so it is a vicious cycle just to
give you an example of that so for
example we know that between the year
2000 and 2018 and our agricultural
expansion actually drove 90 percent of
global deforestation which of course
drives climate change and you know
assad's already mentioned the the
industrialized agriculture model which
has been said to be responsible for
changing the world's surface more than
any other human activity so
that's on the one hand and then in terms
of how it's impacted and our food
production is impacted on by climate
change well unfortunately all we need to
do um is to look over at india where uh
the severe heat wave the hottest spring
on record has severely damaged the wheat
crops and that actually india was hoping
to to export some of which india was
hoping to export uh to help and mitigate
against the supply shock as a result of
the russia ukraine war so it really is
um a potentially vicious cycle and you
know the supply issue also obviously um
drives the high prices here we know that
you know fertilizers
need fossil fuels at the moment
predominantly
in order to be produced and that's
driving up the cost of fertilizers which
in turn
can cause another uh shock next year if
farmers can't afford to use
uh you know what what they've become
used to using because of this current
model of uh industrial agriculture
the fertilizers that they they they need
so it really is a potentially vicious
cycle here
is the future bleak i said do you feel
that the solutions are within reach
is there potential to change
so the solutions have always been within
reach and the solutions have been long
proposed and there are many
organizations that have been proposing
and we've worked for decades around this
issue of hunger and the broken food
system
and its impact on land on biodiversity
in people and so it's not a problem that
can't be fixed but like much of the
climate crisis what it relies on is
political will and political will to
take on some really powerful vested
interest
our food corporations are is about as
strong as the fossil fuel industry and
when we all know we need to end the
fossil fuels but yet we continue to
expand our fossil fuels and leading to
increasing temperature rise we have the
same situation with with food so how do
we change the dial well fundamentally
only we are going to be the people who
can move that make that happen if we
collectively start putting pressure
whether it's on our supermarkets
people power will be the key to this do
you agree briefly people power to change
the climate crisis
yeah i think it needs multiple solutions
really and i think the the reality is is
that we cannot simply try to adapt to
the in terms of food production to these
increasing temperatures we know uh that
uh crop yields will be significantly
impacted uh by rising temperatures so we
do need to really address
the the the carbon emissions and the
methane emissions that are driving a lot
of this crisis as well
okay so much more we could talk on that
subject um but we are out of time on
that question stay with me because i do
have
another topic we want to talk about
meditation now because it's
a mindfulness really it's something
completely different and it's a report
from the guardian newspaper that
officials in brussels are being trained
to meditate to help sort of tackle the
climate crisis it involves walking in
nature and developing mindfulness and
seppie i know you worked in whitehall
for
a while i believe um
do you think this is the solution
well i mean
one thing that used to strike me quite a
lot when i was i worked seven years in
whitehall and you know i always did
wonder you know when there was a flood
in yorkshire or uh you know somewhere
else around the country and then you had
officials sitting
in central london and making policies
for those places i remember thinking
well you know it's one thing to know
something
intellectually it's another thing to
actually experience it and if meditation
can actually help uh you know
officials try to you know go get out
outside of their own um environments
actually help them think more broadly
and it's been shown to increase empathy
then absolutely i think you know
go ahead anything that helps
how about you do you think this is the
key to tackling climate change or is it
all about action
well we need to do both right changing
the system isn't just about policies and
action as as if he said it's also about
empathy and solidarity and seeing
ourselves as part of the world so i
think to solve these problems of course
we need to speak to people's hearts as
well as their minds now look
you know one of the i i've worked at
both at the un at national level and one
of the biggest challenges we've got is
we've created an economic and political
system that promotes short-term economic
interests right it's all about profits
no matter what the cost we've created
ways of making decisions that put a
price on everything but often value
nothing so
we know that there is there is a
sickness in our in our general economy
right we consume more and more we're
greedy for more but we're still not
happy so how do we get across that well
i'm we're all in favor of all of these
bureaucrats walking through nature and
i'm glad they're doing that if they're
going to make better decisions but i'm
we all know that better decisions are
made by those who are mostly impacted
and i would love for them to actually
walk through nature in developing
countries where it's the corporations
and the policies of the eu that
responsible for that destruction or let
them go and actually live in the
communities that are most affected by
decisions and maybe we won't have such a
blase
approach to actually the seriousness of
tackling this climate crisis
assad and sepi thank you very much for
your insights into today's show
well on the show tomorrow we'll be
joined by founder of terror practices
kirsty gogan and co-founder of cop 26
action plan chidioti
but do stay with us because coming up
live from westminster at the take with
sophie ridge with interviews from all
the major parties ahead of tomorrow's
local elections thanks for watching
we'll see you next time bye
[Music]